[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous video uh we had arrived
at these equations uh
which was uh basically a governing
equation for this
kappa a boundary condition and a
connection between the kappa
and the applied load or this or the
supply torque
t so
uh in this video we are going to look at
a way of
uh possibly solving for this unknown
kappa now as a first step towards that
what we'll say is that uh suppose
our our alpha suppose our alpha
is zero so the rate of twist is zero
if the rate of twist is zero then
we are uh sure that
our w the out of plane deflection that
is also going to be zero
because if there is no twist there is
certainly no uh
no out of plane displacement so uh
it is somewhat as part of the
kinematical hypothesis which i had
touched upon very very briefly in the
previous video
what we can say is that alpha
or w
[Music]
that is proportional to alpha
okay and the way that we are going to
say that
is that this w we have already said that
it was equal to this kappa
out of plane deflection and what we are
going to say is that this is just like
some alpha
times
[Music]
phi of x y and this phi
let me write that down in the proper
place
so w is equal to
kappa x y and that is equal to
alpha phi comma xy
and this phi is what is referred to as
the warping function
so what good does it do us well uh let's
see in terms of the equations that we
had
arrived at uh in the previous video so
first of all
uh let us take a look at this
let me just copy it here
[Music]
so first simplification of course is
that this l cancels with this l
so that uh what i'll be
obtaining is g integration
a alpha
x square plus y square
and please note that this kappa now can
be written as this alpha phi
and that alpha is certainly independent
of y
in a similar fashion this kappa can be
represented as alpha phi
and that alpha is also independent of x
so that alpha can come out of this delta
x this alpha can come out of this delta
y
so what we'll have is this alpha
x del phi del y
minus y del phi del x
okay
sorry about that
and this thing of course is
like this let me separate that out
[Music]
and please note that within this so
this alpha is present within this
integration now with respect to this
a and we have this equal to t over here
but this alpha is completely independent
of x and y so it might as well come out
of this integration so what we'll have
is e is equal to
g alpha j where you please note
that this j
is just a placeholder for this entire
integration
alpha x square plus y square
plus alpha whatever was present
[Music]
okay
now next we have this equation
basically this one and that is just the
laplacian of
kappa and again this kappa can be
represented as alpha phi this kappa can
be represented as alpha phi
and alpha being independent of x and y
they can come out of these derivatives
so overall what we'll just end up
with uh is this that uh this
del square kappa del x square plus
del square kappa del y square
is equal to 0 that is just going to give
us
del square phi del x square
plus del square phi del
y square that's all there is to it okay
so this is simply the laplacian
of phi next for this equation
let's see what it gives us uh i'll just
copy this thing
so this is going to give me um
[Music]
so this copper can be replaced uh
replaced by alpha
phi and will have this
alpha coming out so minus y plus del
pi del x
nx plus
alpha x plus
del phi del y
and y is equal to zero
so on the boundary of the cross section
okay and you please note that this alpha
can very much be cancelled out
okay so basically what we are arriving
at
is this equation
this equation and this equation
okay so these are the three things so
let me just
highlight them
these boxed equations are the one that
i'm really concerned with
okay so if you can solve these things
simultaneously uh will be done
and therein lies a little bit of an
issue but let me not
uh let me not uh
talk about issues rather i just first of
all
deal with a very simple case okay see
our our goal here is to solve these
things simultaneously
okay now uh
let us consider the simplest of
situations okay without
thinking too much about the formalism of
solving this equations or the method of
solving this equations
just think about it very very uh in a
very simple
manner suppose we consider
that as a solution for this for this
system of equations
we have phi equal to c see
what is happening here is that we don't
know what phi is because if we know phi
then our job is done okay
so let us just test what happens
if as a very very special case as the
simplest of cases
what happens if we take this phi as
constant
okay so let us test this out so this is
like the simplest of examples
okay simple
simplest case
phi is equal to constant
well one good thing is that if we do
consider phi
as constant then this
governing equation that we have the
laplacian of phi
that gets automatically satisfied there
is no doubt about it
okay you replace phi by some constant
here
the del square del x square of that
constant is 0
similarly the del square del y square of
that constant is 0 so
all considerations apart at least this
governing differential equation
that is nicely satisfied no blocking
there
next let us see what happens to this
boundary condition
okay so
so one thing is for sure is that if you
take this
phi to be a constant then del phi del x
is going to be zero
similarly this term del phi del y is
going to be zero
so what we'll end up with is this minus
y n x
plus x and y let's do that
minus y and x plus
x and y all right
we have this on the boundary
okay
now what can we do well we can just
refer to what we had already arrived
for this nx and ny back in our chapter
on classical plate theory because there
also we were considering a certain
contour or a certain periphery and here
also we are considering the same
periphery
so whether it is a plate or a certain
cross section in terms of the geometry
and the representation in terms of the
different variables it really doesn't
matter
so nx if you can recall
nx is
d y d s and n y
is equal to minus d x e
s okay so i strongly urge you to refer
to that
uh particular video and i'll try to put
a link
to that video in the description below
okay so if we substitute this
we have this
and we have this all good
now this thing
is uh we can write this as so we have a
minus here we have a minus here
so this is we can rewrite this as
dds of
x square plus y square
and if you want you can put a half over
here okay
so if you do the differentiation over
here
you will see that you will get back this
terms these two terms
okay well what is this telling us
please do not forget that we have this
very important statement present
that this equation that we are writing
these are true
for uh for the boundary okay so on the
boundary
it's always there now we have this thing
that dds
of this x square plus y square is equal
to 0 on the boundary
so is it not true that x square
plus y square is equal to some constant
again on the boundary it must be true
but what is that thing x square plus y
square is equal to constant what is that
thing
that is nothing but
so we have to conclude that the boundary
is nothing but a circle
well that's certainly very nice
okay because it's nice because we are
dealing with torsion
and the simplest of cases that we have
considered phi is equal to constant
that is uh uh giving us the situation
back when uh back from our undergraduate
mechanics of solids
classes that this is effectively the
case of the torsion
but let us not forget that we have
another equation also so let's see what
happens to it
so we have t is equal to g alpha j where
this
j is like this okay so let me just uh
uh so i can also simplify this again
uh you see this uh again this phi is a
constant so this term is going to
disappear this term is also going to
disappear
and i'm going to left uh going to be
left with uh
by the way i think i made a mistake here
of writing this alpha game
they should not be present
if this alpha should not be present
because i've already taken this alpha
out
okay sorry about that uh anyway
so i have this uh j but what should have
been present here is the
i think i'm i'm fine all right so
uh i i'm just going to write this as
j is equal to integration
x squared plus y square and this
integration was over the entire domain
okay
and what is this this is nothing but the
very familiar from what again from our
undergraduate
classes there is the familiar polar
movement of inertia
okay from ug classes
so we're getting back all the familiar
things now so
what we are actually getting here is
that
g t is equal to g alpha j
this thing and
this alpha is this
d by t j so this rate of twist or the
twist per unit length
that is that we're getting as t by gj
and again this is something which is
familiar to us and finally
you can note that
so this equation it can give me
[Music]
beta by l because please note that we
have already said
that beta is equal to alpha l
considering the entire length
[Music]
that's like that so beta
is equal to
tl by gj and this again
is something very very very familiar to
us uh we have already come across this
formula in our first year
or maybe in our undergraduate mechanics
of solids classes in our study of
torsion
that the angle of twist
that is actually given by this torsion
times the total length
divided by gj okay and this particular
combination gj
that is referred to as the torsional
rigidity so it's all very nice here
that uh by considering this by uh the
simplest of cases for phi
we are able to recover uh all these
familiar things with regards to the
circle
okay furthermore if we consider slightly
more complicated case
okay suppose we consider something like
uh
phi is equal to
uh a xy
you will see and i encourage you to do
this
yourself uh
you will find that this is for a
for an ellipse phi is equal to
a times y cubed minus three
x squared this is
for an equilateral triangle
now
even though it may uh all these things
mis may seem apparently good
but i believe that i mean by considering
these kinds of files
you are able to recover these geometries
or the cases associated with these
geometries
but i really do believe that
even though you may be happy with these
things uh
apparently happy and especially
with this case where we are considering
the circle
uh or we are obtaining the circle uh
circle uh circular cross section
uh so even though you may be apparently
happy
uh i believe that somewhere in some
corner of your brain
there may be a little bit of an
unhappiness
lurking okay it's like a splinter in
your brain
so whenever you have a situation like
that
that something at the back of your brain
somewhere in some braces
it is uh it is kind of bothering you
i i strongly encourage you to to
completely
and very explicitly acknowledge that
um that that little source of
unhappiness
okay do not try to hide it okay
because only when you acknowledge that
source of unhappiness
uh will you be able to address that
happiness
uh that unhappiness and then possibly
be able to overcome it if you just sweep
it
under the carpet or maybe just hide it
back into some resistance of your brain
you'll never be able to overcome it
okay so even though we have an
apparent happiness over here in order to
gain
true happiness we have to acknowledge uh
the source of that unhappiness that
source of that unhappiness is like this
or here okay
you see we have these governing
equations
okay we have these equations for phi but
we are not really solving for phi
given a certain geometry rather what we
are doing
and this is this is really acknowledging
very explicitly the source of our
unhappiness
is that we are
taking different uh cases for this phi
and then
kind of very coincidentally or
fortunately
arriving at this circular case or this
elliptical case as i've given the
expressions here or the equilateral
triangle case
but would it not be better perhaps much
much better actually
if we had some kind of a method
to directly address a given geometry
instead of doing this kind of a
guesswork with the solution for the
warping function
okay that would have been much better i
am sure most of you will agree with me
so you someone gives you a geometry
you proceed systematically with that
geometry without
guessing uh beforehand
the solution for this five and then
systematically obtain the solution for
this file
that would have been much better i
believe okay so that
so there is a method for doing that uh
and uh that was first given to us uh
by uh ludwig prandtl and this is the
same prandtl
who uh who has given us the famous
boundary layer theory in fluid mechanics
also
all right so on that note i will end
this video and continue
with what is referred to as the parental
stress function in the next video
uh all right thank you very much